mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
sexuelle belästigung am opernhaus zürich
eine direkt involvierte person erhebt
schwere vorwürfe der betatschte die
kollegen unangemessen wenn er sich
unbeobachtet fühlte
zudem dürfen weiße texte von schwarzen
übersetzen
ein brisanter streit um amanda gormans
epochale gedicht und aussortiert oder
gut sortiert wie uns altgediente medien
prägen bis heute unsere sendung aus dem
kunsthaus langenthal
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz jahr die
oper ohne drama das ist undenkbar
aber schmerz und tränen begehren und
verderben
das gehört auf die bühne und bestimmt
nicht dahinter das opernhaus zürich ist
seit wochen in den schlagzeilen der
abrupte abgang von operndirektor michael
fichtenholz gibt anlass zu mutmaßungen
von machtmissbrauch ist die rede
tatsächlich scheint sich dieser verdacht
nun zu erhärten wir unsere recherchen
zeigen eine am opernhaus zürich direkt
involvierte person wird fichtenholz
sexuelle belästigung vor betroffen seien
ihm direkt unterstellten junge sänger
opernhaus zürich theater mit
internationalem renommee hinter der
stattlichen fassade spielt sich in den
vergangenen monaten ein drama im stillen
ab
im zentrum operndirektor michael
fichtenholz
er verantwortet unter anderem die
nachwuchsabteilung und rollenbesetzung
des opernhauses eine person aus dem
künstler ensemble erhebt nun schwere
vorwürfe
es gab partys und empfänge
dort kommentierte herr fichtenholz die
körper von leuten etwa die brüste von
frauen er setzte sich sehr nahe zu
jungen kollegen auch auf ihren schoß er
sagte anzügliche sexuell motivierte
dinge zu ihnen
er betrachte die kollegen unangemessen
wenn er sich unbeobachtet fühlte ich sah
wie er den pro von kollegen tätschelte
an öffentlichen und privaten anlässen
eine weitere quelle bestätigt gegenüber
sf die hier getätigten aussagen grenzen
zwischen privat und beruf seien bei
fichtenholz nicht mehr klar erkennbar
gewesen
herr fichtenholz verschickte
textnachrichten an meine kollegen in
denen er von liebesgefühlen für sie
schrieb er hat ihm direkt unterstellten
jungen opernhaus mitgliedern auch
persönlich seine romantischen gefühle
offenbart das war den kollegen extrem
unangenehm sie zögerten ihn
zurückzuweisen weil sie nicht wussten
wie sich das im job auswirken würde
einige hatten den eindruck dass sie
nicht durch ihn gefördert wurden weil er
sie nicht mochte
andere die er mochte bevorzugte er auch
weil sie an seine partys gingen die
vorfälle melden die belästigungs opfer
an die opernhaus leitung
worauf dieser eine externe fachstelle
einschaltet
kulturplatz weiß dass die untersuchung
gegen fichtenholz mit einem fazit und
einer konkreten empfehlung an den
arbeitgeber endet die folge fichtenholz
kündigt vorzeitig wir wurden informiert
dass herr fichtenholz das opernhaus auf
ende saison verlassen würde
in der mitteilung gab es keinerlei
hinweise darauf was geschehen war
das war enttäuschend weil das opernhaus
eigentlich alles richtig gemacht hatte
bis auf diesen punkt es liegt die
mitteilung an die mitarbeitenden vor für
fichtenholz findet sich darin viel lob
an dieser stelle möchten wir michael von
herzen für seine großartige arbeit am
opernhaus dann
wir bedauern sehr dass michael sich vom
opernhaus verabschiedet
unterzeichnet von opernhaus intendant
andreas homoki und christian berner im
kulturplatz interview nimmt der
kaufmännische direktor stellung zum fall
und der internen mitteilung
die nützliche tipps richtig sie sich
natürlich dem moment wo man entscheidet
dass man untersucht wird bekannt gibt
nur aus meiner kommunizieren und man
muss sich ja irgendwie pizza backen und
demichael fichtenholz zwischen serien
opera direktor was fachkompetenz aber
lang der für staat das mädchen und kann
das mit hier sehr sehr gut und mir herrn
den usa geschlossen ich möchte aber
betonen dass sie dem moment wo es zu
seiner technik und ich stars der branche
sofort der tour und das spricht denn
ehrlichkeit auf sich oder hier
wirtschaft auf engstem raum sehr
körperlich geschafft ballettbühne und so
weiter die hand wie sicher über
belästigung über machtmissbrauch
vertraulichkeit und anonymität
zugesichert und mir glaube es ist
wichtig das lied wo so missstand
artikulieren und autor urteil das zu
artikulieren
sie ruft die diskretion im verlauf und
die mit geschützter raum sind und das
ist wichtig sie das zu respektieren und
die dem moment wo mir zeit hat das
untersucht die hardware sofort und
abklärungen und spekulationen und wer
ist es und was ist es und das möchte die
beteiligten und das sehr stark motiviert
und das auch mit der beteiligten so
besprochen
das netz kommunizieren
die zürcher regierungsrätin jacqueline
fehr sitzt im verwaltungsrat des
opernhauses
dessen stillschweigen stützt sie doch
wird damit ein mutmaßlicher täter nicht
mit geschützt das kann einmal tv sieht
dem konkrete ich es aber nicht
er weiß vor dem fall szene hat sehr
genau um was äs gegangen ist
selbstverständlich ist der betreffende
person ihre name bestätigen und die
andere häuser sind gewalt und die
dancing glaube ich hat meinen guten
mittelweg runde zwischen dem schutz und
der achtung vor der bedürfnis vor den
opfern und den bedürfnis bittere opfers
vermietet
fakt ist am staatstheater karlsruhe ist
fichtenholz als leiter der händel
festspiele nach wie vor engagiert
das opernhaus betont jeder fall von
machtmissbrauch sei einer zu viel
klingt nach umdenken dennoch wer
missstände anprangere müsse nach wie vor
um die karriere fürchten sagt unsere
auskunftsperson während die
machtstrukturen nicht so stark dann
würden sich wohl mehr betroffene trauen
über ihre erlebnisse zu reden jetzt
haben viele angst dadurch ihren job und
ihre karriere zu verlieren
etwas worauf sie ihr leben lang
hingearbeitet haben einstellige ob sie
gekocht
ich denke der fall hätte sicher
sensibilisiert auf sie ich sag jetzt mal
wert war wichtig sind und dass es eine
verlagerung gibt zu soft skills das mic
richtet people skills sozialer faktor
kulturelle faktoren diversität wir
kommuniziert und und ich glaube dass
gott definitiv wieder richtig und wenn
ich das so sagen darf herr anbieter neue
operndirektorin vanger engagiert hat das
- erachtens auch schon sehr stark
verändert ein erster schritt denn
änderungen braucht es ich riskiere
beruflich viel aber das ist es mir wert
die situation war wirklich schlimm ich
möchte weitere kolleginnen und kollegen
davor schützen dass in zukunft das
gleiche miterleben müssen
auf unsere anfragen um stellungnahme hat
mich ein fichtenholz nicht reagiert
die vorgänge am opernhaus zürich
beschäftigen uns weiter meine kollegin
ivana im juli wird zum beispiel morgen
bei radio sf2 kultur über ihre
recherchen zu unserem beitrag berichten
[Musik]
nun aber wollen wir eintauchen in
unseren heutigen schauplatz und damit in
unsere eigene jugend
hier im kunsthaus langenthal wird gerät
im gesicht die dem charme vergangener
zeiten in sich tragen heim für obsoleten
medien heißt die aktuelle ausstellung wo
wir mit objekten in berührung kommen die
unsere biografie prägen diesen begleiter
vergangener tage wird hier neues leben
eingehaucht mit arbeiten von
kunstschaffenden wie etwa diese riesige
installation
es war wohl im frühling 1985 als ich von
meinem schatz ein mixtape bekommen habe
ja und diese kassette habe ich in meinem
walkman solange abgespielt bis das tape
wie auch die erste liebe etwas ins land
kam ja und mein vater er wäre nicht mein
vater ohne diashow und super 8 kamera
meine kinder jedenfalls ist bestens
dokumentiert was sind ihre erinnerungen
an diese geschichtsträchtigen geräte das
wollten wir von bekannten kultur
persönlichkeiten wissen
sie waren allgegenwärtig
praktisch günstig und hat das größte der
glücksgefühle draußen unterwegs sein und
gleichzeitig musik hören das
einzigartige lebensgefühl dieser
analogen zeit hallt bis heute nach
auch bei so manchem schweizer
kulturmanager
man hat nicht einfach gehabt
verfügbarkeit sondern man hat den film
sagt kartte wiedererlangung spielt laut
boston und dann ist man mit der erhalten
und hat die revanche der platte spiele
gleich voraus doch zwei ein stück mal im
radio hörte die ganze platte kann mini
allererst die trägerschicht cdu und
logistikkosten gemacht es habe damals
noch das material hat extrem tür kostet
das heißt du hast du vor ruß müsse ganz
genau überlegen was möglich war
schlimmer als nur darf keine ahnung
haben und einfach filme der filmemacher
samir hat seine ersten werke in den 80er
jahren mit dieser 16 mm kamera gedreht
sie hatte das jetzt kassierte zum
beispiel immer 16 mm liegt hat im
dunklen tauschte firmino dann hat man da
durch den schlitz liter ca
auf der anderen seite ist auf jeden
besucher da dann hat man dadurch die
zahle die matura für deutsche anbieter
für und da ist der film beleuchtet wurde
weil man da der kamera ihnen
gesetzt hat samir ist auch bekannt für
seine frühe experimentierfreudigkeit mit
video oder super 8 film das bewegte bild
hat und mit dem super auch dieses mal an
wie die sind so 67 hat sich eine ganz
simple lecker haben es erst mal um sage
ich jetzt mal ist es ist vielmehr
volkstümlich worden
der siegeszug der technik für alle war
unaufhaltsam
in allen künsten
[Musik]
die musikerin dodo hug nahm in den 90er
jahren ihre lieder noch analog auf vor
der studioproduktion experimentierte sie
jeweils mit kassetten geräten trophy sie
mit mit nobody liegt mit grippe also mit
reddoxx mit sony auf genau salm salm
ruft auf afrikanischer typs meistens
monique sein könne und ich hatte ein
klebt zu gott mal zweispurig aufnehmen
und dann später mit mit kassette gerät
vierspurig of snow und können nach höhle
vorbereiten und zur sache
das kann ich heute aber ich finde das
ist es sondern dass sich 2000 1000 1000
tausend mögliche und wählen sind das
nicht unbedingt kreativ im gegenteil
sich ablenken
daniel rohr leitet das theater rigiblick
in zürich für die stücke lässt er sich
immer wieder von seiner plattensammlung
inspirieren um am regal für die und und
finde da hatten wir schon lange nicht
getan es dauerte von vivaldi und ich
finde das ist einfach unglaublich schön
und los das wiederum findet dann das
wieder offen idee nur noch auf der bühne
sind seine schallplatten auch mal fester
bestandteil eines stücks china aufs
smartphone gefällig oder lieber dynamik
mit laserstrahlen hier kommt killer
queen
[Musik]
die alpen elektronischen medien sind
also ganz und gar nicht überflüssig
geworden
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt mental immer mehr auf
digitalen umgestiegen
aber man ist freue er sich besonders
theologie bild mit mit dem hohen kräne
und ich danke ihm nach der
dokumentarfilm wirklich auch barometer
auf 16mm konzept verschaffen wie
zwischen 15 und 20 cds eine bar mit mix
dann könnte wieder und es gibt da viele
das ganze mehr frauen als männer wo sie
mit dem gezeter wie fix ist wer
mitspielt hat durchaus eine tour im auto
industriemuseum kritikerin und machen
und ich glaube dass das schätzen
natürlich schaffe mit dem computer
natürlich schaffen mit spotify scharfer
mit youtube das ist ganz klar mit denen
es auch auf 4.000 klar mit recherche
aber letztendlich und ich es gern wenn
ich an absätze der glatten fläche der
den wirklichen eine höhere kurse
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das waren noch zeiten tom jones at its
best flughafen an die hand das
langenthaler viele geräte und auch
gleich nach sich selber bricolage
universal
was hat es zu bedeuten ich halte die
schönste besetzung universalbank negativ
dotiert
die offenheit für alles ist möglich
ich habe irgendwie das ist rang fragen
ob sie und das entspricht einfach die
kamine tätig
es geht um nachhaltigkeit gebaut aber
ein staubsauger oben zu finden sind das
heißt also ich dann doch baustoff
höheren niveau ja das ist schon das
dritte und wichtigste auf der
straßenkarte und genau das ist jetzt das
1000 des reaktors die darstellung
angriffe hoch aber es sollte eine wand
von hundt gibt schon wie wichtig den
ständen wo sind denn die wurzeln von der
liegenschaft bienen sind die kinderstube
so cassius der schlimmste zeit mit sich
schleppt und sperrmüll sich steiner
vereinsführung scores also ja es ist
klar zu sagen also hat er verbaut das
ist wahrscheinlich das ist motivation
sie sich richtig motivation zu ja du
wirst du nie wieder schafft wieder gange
nach der kindertag abgewiesen der
fernsehen das hat auch daheim blieben
werde ich schauen ja eine sache hätte
dass das haupt ist die hebamme gesät
denn auch relativ günstiges e5 sturz
wahnsinnig viele flecken und das ist das
neue medium zu überlegungen dass das ist
das ist ein hobby wie jackpot das
angebaute schmieden und selbermachen und
gemerkt es geht auch um so verliebt dass
krümmel und die realität schaut danach
die höhere ebene zu mir und hoffe dass
ich das mit globetrotter die maschine
nach neuerlichen entwicklungen noch ein
navi grad noch mutiger aus um die worte
nur managerin ist haben sie nur dort
wie ist es überhaupt zu so das ist auf
15 kunststoffen sie auch deren
leidenschaft frönen vorvergangenen
medien also die direkte von kutchers
langenthal wieso legen morgen minister
zu gange noch das ist durchaus klage
eines mietvertrages wie ist seine
wunschbesetzung ist beendet so etwas
geht zu behaupten dass man die sachen
entdecken und zu jedem medium und zu
werden
thematik sich künstler eingeladen
künstler habe zugesagt das sehr schön
ist so kraft
[Musik]
gebannt vor dem radio gerät zu sitzen
und einem boxkampf ein fußballspiel zu
verfolgen
von solchen erlebnissen berichten unsere
eltern oder großeltern wenn wir uns 19
20 21 erinnern werden dann erinnern wir
uns auch an ein historisches hör und
seherlebnis ich spreche von der
inauguration des amerikanischen
präsidenten joe biden im januar als die
junge poetin am ende kommen mit einem
gedicht die welt verzauberte doch an der
frage wer diesen lyrischen text nun
übersetzen soll entbrannte eine debatte
und zwar darüber ob weise überhaupt
texte von schwarzen übersetzen dürfen
in den niederlanden etwa gab es protest
gegen die weiße autorin marieke lukas
reinefeld und victor obwohl der
katalanische übersetzer des gedichts
wurde plötzlich von seinem verlag
zurückgepfiffen lange vor dieser debatte
hat der verlag hoffmann und campe an
ganz anderen weg gewählt
[Musik]
ein neuer tag und wir fragen uns wo wir
licht finden sollen
im nicht enden wollenden schatten ein
text mit symbolkraft jung und wie ein
signal an ein amerika das erwacht und
den alptraum abschütteln wie der das
land so sehr spaltet
wenn man als verlag die aufgabe hat ein
solches gedicht in eine andere sprache
zu übertragen dann geht damit natürlich
eine besondere verantwortung einher
zumal im männer kommen ja eben auch eine
lyrikerin ist die dringende politische
anliegen hat sie kämpft gegen rassismus
sie setzt sich für vielfalt in der
gesellschaft ein und aus diesem gedanken
heraus sind wir auf die idee gekommen
drei übersetzerin zu beauftragen die
jeweils unterschiedliche
erfahrungswelten unterschiedliche
expertisen mit einbringen und die in
ihrer vielfalt auch im ender gorman
entsprechen
drei unterschiedliche perspektiven auf
den text dreimal je an andere blick von
der übersetzerin oder strätling der
rassismus forscherin hadija haruna lk
unter autorin kübra gümüsay gab keine
festgelegte struktur es gab keine klaren
rollenverteilung also es waren ja ganz
offene geschichte und technisch für mich
insofern neu als wir online simultan im
ständigen gespräch direkt am text zu
dritt gearbeitet haben es gab natürlich
stellen wie zum beispiel um eines
herauszugreifen wie übersetzen wir color
was ist das jetzt im deutschen wir
können nicht einfach mit farbig
übersetzen das war uns aus unserer
perspektive rassismus kritischer
perspektive klar oder nicht klar frage
weil manche wissen das gar nicht und
dann und dann vielleicht gar nicht sich
damit beschäftigen sondern einen anderen
weg zu finden der gut klingt
[Musik]
ein land für menschen aller art jeder
kultur und lade jeden schlag und so
lenken wir den blick nicht auf das was
zwischen uns steht sondern auf das was
vor uns liegt nachdem welche übersetzung
man wählt wird man ja auch macht auch
seine deutungshoheit aus und bestimmt
dass das gemeinsam und es gab immer
wieder punkt alle gemerkt haben dass je
nachdem welchen weg wir sehen welche
deutungshoheit wir sozusagen hier nutzen
wollen wir ganz andere wege und pfade
dann sozusagen folgen und in den
momenten haben wir wenn diese zu sehr
die reagierten tatsächlich gesagt lasst
uns doch einfach die autoren direkt
fragen single dreaming präsident
wir treten das erbe eines landes und
einer zeit an da ein kleines dünnes
schwarzes mädchen nachfahren von sklaven
kind einer alleinerziehenden mutter
davon träumen kann
präsidentin zu werden wir haben sie ja
auch gefragt bei zwei punkten wo wir uns
tatsächlich einfach nicht finden konnten
und da ging es um die besetzung von
slade und im deutschen sklaven halt
einfach ein genetisches maskulinum und
wir halten aber kein sternchen benutzen
weil die anschlussfähigkeit ganz viele
menschen sein wollten die sich zum
beispiel mit dieser debatte nicht
auskennen und haben deshalb dann die
frage gestellt welche optionen zu leben
könnte und also ob sie auch damit leben
könnte wenn wir ein generisches familien
nutzen also von sklavinnen sprechen und
damit konnte sie leben doch was steht
hinter der debatte
wer mit welcher identität texte
schwarzer autorinnen und autoren
übersetzen soll
texte aus fremden erfahrungswelten texte
so besonders wie der von amanda foreman
ist die arbeit im team ein modell für
die zukunft situation und da war es
natürlich sehr wichtig dass eine
besondere sensibilität auch da
hereingebracht wird in den umgang mit
dem text und so fern war das nur
folgerichtig also da nach
übersetzerinnen zu suchen die die alle
perspektiven und alle akzente
entsprechend auch setzen können oder
sehen können und miteinander daneben
versuchen dass eine klangliche gestalt
auch zu überführen
es geht ja auch darum wer erklärt uns
die welt durch dessen augen betrachten
die die welt und wer darf deutungshoheit
ausüben und ich ließ deshalb aus dieser
debatte um die übersetzung auch eine
angst heraus vor einem bedeutungsverlust
ich glaube das ist ein wegbereiter für
möglichkeiten einfach erst zu denken ich
glaube wenn verlage sich die gedanken
machten das heißt dass das ist natürlich
ein meinte dass es ein verständnis von
wie die welt der vielen wie die
gesellschaft der vielen alle
unterschiedlich sein lässt aber
nebeneinander das ist ist sogar teil des
gedichts und darüber nachzudenken wenn
das verlage tun dann dann sind wir
wirklich ein thema
[Musik]
ein neuer tag wir treten heraus aus dem
schatten entflammt unerschrocken ein
neuer morgen dämmert darauf indem wir es
sagen denn licht ist immer wenn wir es
nur in uns zu finden waren
wenn wir uns zutrauen es weiter zu
tragen
mit poesie die welt bewegen das geht den
beweis lieferte länder kommentieren
kunsthaus langenthaler können sie
schwelgen in erinnerungen an die ihrer
show und super 8 film noch bis ende juni
wir melden uns nächste woche wieder mit
der frage wie werden wir in zukunft
reisen ja gleich geht's hier weiter auf
sf1 mit der dänischen serie die wege des
herrn kommen sie gut durch die woche ist
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos